we're gonna do the halftime show at the
Super Bowl talk to me about that will
your breasts pop out a lot Janet Jax
absolutely not and if I could throw my
stylus so I love so much under the buzz
press and all the other day heat from
time to time will glue my underwear to
my you know what is up with that to your
vagina without even asking because he's
a second like you don't even know
well because my show you this little
rhinestone shorts ahead I'm in their
little are you glued into your I'm not
glued today but I was glued and that's
you know and I didn't know and when I
was over okay so what happens was I was
getting ready for the show right and I
had this little rhinestone you know that
first outfit first outfit right and so
Brandon you know he's getting me ready
and um he never can watch when I go out
cuz he's so except it's gonna stop out
but you're not uptight no I'm not but
you know it's not really a great idea to
have something pop out the way your
album release alive a television so he
did I disagree and he glued my hair so
does he put the glue in your underwear
before you put it on and then when you
put it on you're like oh [ __ ] yeah but
he didn't tell me so he just did it oh
when the show was over I went to the
bathroom and I'm like what's up I can't
get my underwear type of glue is he
putting I don't know it's a [ __ ] glue I
am so [ __ ] shocked by what you're
telling me
oh you're shocked can you imagine not
being told information like imagine if
someone just glued your boxers to your
dick right before stage and then in fact
like can you imagine no if someone did
that they might be fired and then I'm on
my phone like texting him like why don't
you tell me